(candies glisten)
(bell tree tinkles)
(sci-fi computer revs up)
(tape fast-forwards)
(Andy swallows loudly)
(dramatic electronic
orchestral music)
- [Digitized Woman's voice]
Welcome to cluster fest.
- Here's the pitch: It's you,
inside Andy Samberg's stomach.
Want in?
- Where am I?
This is Cluster fest?
- Hi.
- Whoa, look at that (bleep).
- What is this place?
- Cluster fest.
I get it.
- When you show me
your toothpaste,
I'll show you my toothpaste.
- Do you wanna float
amongst the stars?
- Mmmmmmm.
- Cluster fest is fun
for the whole family.
(alien ship fires a laser)
- Robots are taking our jobs.
- [Female Voiceover] Do you
experience Action Bronson,
Bert Kreischer, Ali
Siddiq, and Doughboys?
If so, ask your doctor is
Cluster fest is right for you.
Rare but serious reactions can
occur, such as Josh Johnson,
Last Podcast on the Left,
anilingus, Michelle Collins,
Sam Jay, asparagus pee,
Shane Torres, and Tim Dillon.
Some patients experience
low but not insignificant
sexual side-effects.
Cluster fest is
habit forming with
guaranteed sexual side effects.
What we're saying is
your dick won't work.
Don't be shy, ask your
doctor about Cluster fest,
The number one
preferred brand of--
(hip hop music)
- Wow, this is so real,
like definitely real.
- It's vivid as (bleep).
(hip hop music)
- She ready.
- Bridget, you wearin' a bra?
Nope, don't need
one, next question.
- There's nothing I love more
than nothing that makes sense.
- You know what I like
more than anything?
- Hi, I'm Kyle.
- Sex.
- [Female Voiceover]
Step into the worlds
of your favorite comedies.
- [Voiceover] Step right up
to the South Park County Fair.
(crowd applauds)
- Alright, check it out.
- What's all the hoo ha?
(television static scratches)
- [Voiceover] The Daily Show
presents the Donald J. Trump
Presidential Twitter Library.
Sad, Sad.
- [Woman's Voice] Have
a drink in Paddy's Pub.
- You can never leave.
- [Digitized Man's
Voice] Ding dong,
Las Culturistas calling.
And we'll see you
at Cluster fest.
- [Whispered Voiceover]
Push it, push it real good.
- California
- San Francisco, what's up?
(trippy EDM music)
(crowd applauds)
- [Digitized Man's Voice] Whoa
- There's no way we're just
in that white room, right?
- Not a chance.
- Impossible.
- Yo, we are not
there, we are here.
- [Man's Voice] And cut.